the problem with liberalism and so I I I
spent a lot of time uh reading and
researching into liberalism itself as a
philosophy cuz so much of it goes unsaid
right we we assume the truth of all of
the presuppositions underpin liberalism
but actually there are some real flaws
with it and one of the main things I
took away from it is that liberalism is
an incomplete philosophy right it's not
a philosophy for Life what it is is kind
of a way of recognizing when the state
is going too far right when you are
being actively oppressed which we've
seen recently in the example of Russell
Brand actively being persecuted I mean
what what what's happening to Russell
Brown by the British government at the
moment is a violation of article 39 of
Magna Carta yeah like a man without the
lawful Judgment of his peers under the
law of the land shall not be
transgressed upon or pressed upon by the
state that's literally what it says and
it and this is what we're watching
happening in real time so it's it's not
enough to just be a
liberal
do I call you Carl or do I call you
Sargon of aod now that we are officially
sitting down once again after many
years I think K will do Carl will do do
all right there is a lot I want to talk
about with you and I said to you right
before we started of all weeks for you
to be in America cuz you live across the
pond You Came the very week that we're
opening up this studio to inperson
guests and for people who do not know
who haven't been with me since the
beginning of the beginning when I was
waking up to the left what's going on
with the left why are we calling
everybody racist no one's actually
acting liberally yeah the Sargon of a
Cod story everybody online all the
commenters said Dave you got to watch
this guy Saron of aad I don't know that
your face was even in the videos at that
time but everybody said you got to watch
SAR you got I started watching your
video I'm going wow this guy's a liberal
and he makes sense and then eventually
we started talking you had me on your
show and in some ways the rest is
history so I think I've done it once or
twice over the years but I give you
serious cred uh for getting me here
today because you were one of the first
in that way
so tell give the people like the
two-minute bio about you first and then
we'll get into the politics and the
fighting and the craziness and the state
of the world and the rest of yeah yeah
and welcome to the free state of Florida
it's beautiful it's so much nicer than
California there's Greenery around right
I'm from England so if I'm I'm not
surrounded by Greenery I get a bit weird
and edgy and California is just this
brown blasted hellscape of dirt whereas
Florida it's luscious genuinely luscious
um speaking my language it it's crazy
cuz I I was the same though in for me it
happened in about 2012 2013 where I I
was just I wasn't even like a hard
liberal I was just like well no I'm a
liberal person and I believe in you know
basic liberal ideals which most of us
really do even even the quite
conservative people will say well
actually yeah I mean obviously I want
rule of law freedom of speech and
property rights and all these sorts of
things right fairly fairly basic stuff
so it's not stuff we had to think about
too often and then we had this very
aggressive and what I now after the fact
have learned is just essentially an open
communist Insurrection within liberalism
and at the time they weren't publicly
like that you know it's it's actually
been quite far on that you've got Hass
being like yes I'm a communist here's my
red flag you know beneath beh behind it
which is you know okay fair enough at
least at least the masks off right
because before they would say I'm a
liberal but everything around you is
racist and we need to redistribute all
the wealth SE the property I'm like
that's that's not very liberal well
that's refreshing to hear that they're
giving up the mantle of liberalism that
would be nice that would be nice because
they're actually the most illiberal
people on the planet of course and and
they know it as well that's the thing
they are well aware that they're just
like right okay what can we do to kind
of explode liberalism from the the
inside and and honestly they've done a
good job of it but wait before we get to
them and everything else what so so it's
it's 2011 2012 you're saying you know
I'm just kind of a liberal I'm a liberal
guy but now you're doing some stuff on
YouTube or what what was waking you up
that kind of made you get into this I
was trying to develop a video game and
obviously being in that sort of space
you start becoming aware of like well
feminism frankly coming in and attacking
the industry as a whole and I was just
like okay what is this I looked into it
and like okay this isn't really in line
with the principles that basically
everyone is espousing why are we why are
we stigmatizing men and of course then
that leads on to the stigmatization of
white people and straight people and
anything that they view as what they
call a dominant class um it gets
stigmatized in order to try and tear it
down and so I I started making videos
just in 2013 was July 2013 was my first
video where I was just like look I don't
really agree with this and I don't
really understand why you're saying it
and I think and and looking back right I
watched my very first video a few years
ago man I was naive man I was na well we
all were we all were right because and
we were we genuinely were it was it was
like okay why don't I just explain why I
think you're wrong and then we'll have a
discourse and they were like oh you're a
misogynist I was like you know and I was
outraged the first time I was called a
misogynist I was genuinely out raced I
like of course I'm not a misogynist you
know why would you even say that it's
fair for me to have a critique of your
philosophy no you just hate women it's
like oh right okay you know but of
course you know duck water off of ducks
back these days because you can't
critique black Liv matter feminism
anything but being an istop phobe you
know obviously that's become very
apparent that they just use that as a
sort of defense mechanism try and shut
you up but I think that really that's
that time has passed I think everyone 10
years later the uh the words don't
matter as much as they used to back then
exactly everyone's like immune to that
kind of attack now and and yeah and so I
just started talking about these things
from my perspective which really is
still the perspective of a classical
liberal you know I've I've I've
developed an appreciation of
conservatism like real sort of halfy
conservatism you know the sort of
genuine sort of bonds of sentiment that
tie together people and place and
Community Building outwards to nation
and to humanity you know I've really
spent a lot of time reading their
philosophy because they're actually
really bad at articulating it you know
you you probably can't actually name
very many conservative philosophers but
you can name dozens of leftwing ones
right you know and so it's kind of
annoying that the conservatives are
actually quite bad at telegraphing their
message that's just a really wholesome
message you know really what the most
what's the most important thing in your
life well your family actually the
people who depend on you you know and so
I've kind of been leaning into that a
bit more but you know I've still got the
same sort of classical liberal core
where it's like well obviously people
should be treated as individuals in
decent ways but there's more to the good
life than just being an atomized
individual on your own you know with
just a bunch of things given to you by
the state there's actually a lot more to
the good life than that um and so yeah I
just continued developing I've matured a
lot uh and which is never fun to say
right because it's it's you know you
realize well it depends where you end up
I suppose well yeah yeah but it's it's
never fun to say but I've definitely
matured a lot and uh I started a
business called lot.com where we develop
um sort of I I hate to say say it's
right-wing philosophy but like I don't
really have a better term for it you
know because everything else seems to be
well left wi philosophy so okay well I
guess you know but what we're really
trying to do is just properly understand
the sort of metaphysics of what it is we
actually assume fume all day every day
cuz we never talk about the importance
of not just family cuz it's easy to say
that and it's tried to say that it's
like okay what what about it the family
actually is at this important and it's
really the bonds of reliability on the
person right because one one thing
having four kids has taught me it's the
predictability of each day is what's
really good for the your children it's
really what they need they need to wake
up and know Dad's going to do this mom's
going to do this I'm going to go to
school and everything will be the same
as it was yesterday and it'll be the
same tomorrow and so they can genuinely
be happy in the world around them and
then when you start thinking like this
you realize God the people in charge are
totally irresponsible with everything in
our state you know everything in the
country everything in the west you know
they're just so Cavalier with the
decisions that they make and it's like
God how can they think like this and I
think a lot of it is because we've kind
of Lent too much towards liberalism and
not enough towards what should be a
happy marriage between liberalism and
conservatism I'm with you brother I feel
I get it it's why now I say to my I say
to my audience I can call myself a
conservative I I I'm married to a man
that's not very conservative in in the
sense that it would have been thought of
say 50 years ago but I do believe in the
family and I believe in the importance
of community and things like that do do
you think that you sort of hinted at
this but do you think that liberalism
had an inherent flaw that allowed The
Barbarians at the gate and then kind of
to open the door to the gate or open the
door to the castle the the problem the
problem with liberalism and so I I I
spent a lot of time uh reading and
researching into liberalism itself as a
philosophy because so much of it goes
unsaid right we we assume the truth of
all of the presuppositions underpin
liberalism but actually there are some
real flaws with it and one of the main
things I took away from it is that
liberalism is an incomplete philosophy
right it's not a philosophy for Life
what it is is kind of a way of recog
izing when the state is going too far
when you are being actively oppressed
which we've seen recently in the example
of Russell Brand actively being
persecuted I mean what what what's
happening to Russell Brown by the
British government at the moment is a
violation of article 39 of Magna Cara
yeah like a man without the lawful
Judgment of his peers under the law of
the land shall not be transgressed upon
or pressed upon by the state that's
literally what it says and it and this
is what we're watching happening in real
time so it's it's not enough to just be
liberal but liberalism is great in that
regard in that sort of narrow band it's
really good to say look these are the
these are the rules and the boundaries
that have been kind of learned from
English political tradition and then
that way they can be spread around the
world brilliant idea but on the other
side it lacks a kind of normative
Doctrine as in you know you get up what
should you do today and actually
liberalism doesn't have any answers to
this and so this gives the whole world
of what where conservatives and
Christians in particular have lots of
good answers for what you should do
today no you should get up what you
should make your kids breakfast you know
you should get them to school you should
go to work you should uphold the right
ordering of the world in your actions in
the character of what you do and
liberalism really can't say that and so
that's why liberalism is kind of
vulnerable because if actually you take
away the Christianity you take away the
conservative values then you can take
the liberal principles of Freedom
equality and say right I can explode
these out into everything you know the
freedom to never be bothered by another
human being so you're just an isolated
individual who's that I'm I'm free to
take as many drugs as I want I'm free to
just become dependent on the government
oh we want equality now right okay well
how do you get equality well you've got
to make sure the lowest never have the
highest never have more than the lowest
so you've got to tax them to equality
it's like well hang on a second that's
not good right or just or fair I I would
say that's not liberal but it's what
liberalism is devolved into you're
basically saying there was no there was
no stop sign along the way so it was
would once you take away all the other
considerations about like the richness
of human life then actually you can take
liberal principles and explode them into
things they're not meant to be you know
and this is the problem I think that the
left has right now and why so many
people are just like okay I I used to be
part of the left but I'm not that if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop screaming check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell